[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
VIVIAN SONG: In
this video, I will
be going over Goodie Bag number
eight, which is about reactions
and reaction rates.
What you'll need are pH strips,
small measuring cups, stirrers,
gloves, citric powder, cups,
a scale, and seashells.
No sea animals were harmed in
the making of this Goodie bag.
The objectives are to understand
how climate change has
caused ocean acidification.
Assess the order of the
reaction from empirical data.
Learn how temperature can
affect the reaction rate.
And measure the pH of a
reaction using pH strips.
Some conceptual
questions to think about
are, what is the reaction order?
And how does the
reaction rate change
if the temperature increases or
if we have outside pH effects?
Now, in this Goodie bag, we will
be exploring the application
of reaction rates in
ocean acidification
due to climate
change and what that
means for many sea animals.
As you can see from
this graph, there
is a strong positive correlation
between increasing carbon
dioxide levels in
the atmosphere, which
is marked by the red,
and decreasing pH
in the ocean, which corresponds
to increasing acidity, as seen
in the green.
What exactly is going on
in terms of the chemistry?
First, carbon dioxide from the
air dissolves into the oceans
and reacts with water
to form carbonic acid.
Then the carbonic
acid donates a proton.
Finally, calcium
carbonate from seashells
reacts with excess
protons in solution
to formed bicarbonate ions.
What does this all mean?
Seashells are dissolving
in a more acidic ocean,
which is very sad.
One final note about the slide.
I've only drawn the
forward reaction arrows.
But these reactions are
actually reversible.
So there should also
be backward arrows.
However, the forward
reactions are
more dominant to the
reverse reactions.
So the net product is that
of the forward reaction.
Now, let's dive
into the experiment
and see this happen
in real life.
First, take out one
of your seashells
and weigh it with your scale.
Next, put on your
elegant nitrile gloves.
And take a large plastic cup and
have it filled with tap water
about halfway.
Measure out two scoops
of the citric powder
using the small but
accurate measuring cup.
And put it into the water.
Then stir while
using the stirrer
until all of the citric
powder is fully dissolved.
It might take a
minute of stirring,
but the water should
look pretty clear.
After that, you can
use your pH strip
to measure the pH
of the solution.
Have a timer ready.
And when you're ready,
place the shells
that you weighed into
the low pH solution.
And record what you observe.
After 20 minutes, take out
the shells with your gloves
on and record the exact time.
Let the shells dry for
maybe half an hour or so so
that all the water
has evaporated.
And then measure the weight.
Repeat this step
two more times so
that you have data points of the
mass of the shell at zero, 20,
and 40 minutes.
The pH that I measured
was a pH of 2,
as you can see using
this pH tester.
While doing the
experiment, you should
see that the sea
shells are dissolving
in the acidic solution.
And here, I've captured a
hyper-lapse of this happening.
The focus of our
experiment is to figure out
the reaction rate of the
dissolution of calcium
carbonate.
As a reminder, the reaction
rate is equal to some rate
constant times the
concentration of the calcium
ions to the n power times the
concentration of carbonate ions
to the n power, where n plus n
is equal to the reaction order.
And that is determined
empirically from the data
that we've gathered.
As you can see from the data,
this reaction is 0th order.
I plotted the concentration
of carbonate ions
on the y-axis, which
you can figure out,
assuming that you poured
0.2 liters of water
in your experiment,
and time on the x-axis.
Because this plot looks linear,
the rate is constant over time
and does not depend on the
concentration of carbonate ions
already in solution.
Thus, this is a
0th order reaction.
You could also imagine the
same plot with calcium ions
since we know that the calcium
ions and carbonate ions exist
in a one-to-one molarity ratio.
In summary, the
reaction rate order
is determined empirically.
And the reaction rate can
depend on temperature and pH.
Now, we didn't have time to
do this pH and temperature
dependence experiment
in the video.
But you can imagine how
temperature and pH might
affect your reaction rate.
And finally, ocean acidification
linked to climate change
is causing our seashells to
dissolve, which is very sad.